that are happening in the world
today it's only
right that we speak about what's
happening in
Palestine it's only right that since
we're all congregated here
together in unity as
Muslims for us also to
remember the struggle the true struggle
of our brothers in a sham region in
Palestine where many of the Hadith of
the end
days the
Mal the signs of the end times are
related to that specific
J and when I see the images as I'm sure
you do as
well of
children young girls in the hands
of women and
men at the
hands of the
zionists who have tried
to and continue to oppress our brothers
and sisters for 75
years there's no doubt that that fills
me with a
rage that I haven't felt for a long
time does it fill you with the
rage
let me ask that question again because I
want to understand and gauge the
emotional reaction of the people here in
Birmingham does it fill you with a
[Applause]
rage does it make you angry to see young
children
crying on the
floor under Rubble because of the
Cowardly zionists that are afraid of
face Toof face
confrontation does it make you angry to
know that in the very country that we're
living in that our political
leaders have no word of condemnation to
say about those children does
it are we as the Muslim
people going to accept them trying to
gag us and to shut us up and to tell us
that waving the Palestinian flag is an
Act of terrorism is that what we're
going to
expect we're not going to accept that
here in birmingam in London or anybody
anywhere
else this is an important
thing and it's more than just Dua
although that is the most important
thing that we can
do raising Awareness on this
issue is extremely
important but I want to say something to
tie it to the themes of
today when you
see the zionists attacking children at
this level where they become less than
human effectively and some of them are
speaking in this way they're saying
we're fighting Human
animals wall if we were over a zoo of
animals if we the people here
went together and we went to the N the
the local zoo and we sprayed white
phosphorus over the zoo because we
claimed there was a few dangerous
animals inside of
it and we indiscriminately bombarded
that Zoo they would call us terrorists
because we are attacking the
animals but when these people see our
own children little
[Applause]
girls in the hands of their parents
they don't actually see it as much as
they see their dog at home that licks
their face because they are people of
NASA the dog and the cat that they have
at home the pet in this country I
guarantee you they rate those animals
they respect those animals they love
those animals more than they love
us W it's not just the people of
Palestine those elements do zionists and
their supporters they are dehumanizing
every single one of you and it's not
just the
zionists and their supporters there are
many segments of society unfortunately a
growing number that feels that way about
us some of them want to take our bodies
and the other ones want to take our
soul we need to learn
now that we're not going to be able to
Ally with these people at all whether
it's the
leftwing who are forcing our children
lgbtq brainwashing in our
schools even though it's against their
understanding of Human Rights because
according to the Charter we have a right
to educate our own children according to
our views according to the human rights
yet they're forcing our children this
trying to take their souls away from
them and on the right wing wall they
don't care if you're alive or
dead this is the environment that we're
living
in we have no time to
bicker in the
da the the IMs we have no time to B do
we do we have time do we have time for
this
Unity these matters are the matters in
which we must come together together
on we as the Muslim um must come
together as one J one
body the prophet Muhammad sallahu alaihi
wasallam said the Muslim to the other
Muslim is like one body in another
Hadith he
says like a
building it pulls itself
together
those elements in society will never
accept
you those Jews and Christians will never
accept you the Quran says until you
follow their
way so do men and women and our families
husbands and wives do we have the luxury
of being at each other's throats at
being in a war with each other at
disuniting the family of
doing which is one of the major sins of
Al Islam where the Prophet Muhammad sah
alaihi wasallam he
said the one who cuts the ties of
kinship will not enter
Jenna and we have
people withholding the children from
their
father we have people not speaking to
their mother we have people not
discussing you have relatives that you
don't even speak to how are we meant to
face the
world when we can't even face our own
families we can't even get unity in your
own
home you're incapable because you hold
grudges we hold
grudges and we have and and envy and and
anger and
resentment Allah asked is it not time
for the Believers for their hearts to be
softened by the remembrance of
Allah it is
time it is time what can you do for
Palestine what can you do for the
oppressed Muslims all over the world
start with your own homes start with
your own
communities enough is enough of this
Masjid attacking this Masjid on this for
of trivial and periperal issues we've
got big issues we have zionists trying
to take over Masjid AA killing our
children we have LGBT we have the
feminists we have this one this one
wants to take your soul and this one
wants to take your body and we're
fighting each other is that
reasonable is it reasonable no
what we will do therefore I'm not asking
you pledge for money or charity or
fundraising but make a pledge within
yourself that when you go back home to
your families that you will and I will
and we
will swallow our
pride we will swallow our
pride if your wife is upsetting you you
see the bigger picture I'm doing this
for the family I will discipline her in
the right
manner if your husband is upsetting you
instead of having the and this and that
no we have
children this is we've got a bigger
picture because the families make up the
communities and the communities make up
the
umah it all starts from in
here from from within your
heart
cleaning
removing being forgiving being generous
being good and then realizing that we
have a priority at hand when that
happens like w I tell you this I've been
in the public Sphere for about 9 years
now this is the 10th year this time
round haven't you noticed that with this
issue of Palestine there's been more
Unity than ever have you noticed that
have you noticed that our voices are
louder than ever have you noticed that
we're stronger than ever have you
noticed that social media has changed
the game have you noticed that they're
acquiescing have you noticed that
they're on the back
foot have you noticed that they're weak
yes have you noticed them
shiver have you notice them tremble I
have noticed them tremble they R their
top heads
we have something that these people
don't have our God is not the god of
money is
it the prophet
said perished is the one who is the
slave of a dinar and Dirham money is
your God because that's a weak God and
so you have weak resolve weak motivation
two days you can't handle it on Twitter
imagine in the battlefield but then you
have children that throw rock and go in
and say I'm ready to die child a child
in Palestine the gift of Iman that gives
us the courageous the gness The Bravery
the will to live the purpose all the
things these people even if they bought
the whole world they would not be able
to achieve it is a gift no other people
can have we have
[Music]
that they would wish to have that if
they knew how it felt if they knew what
it meant they
would as the salaf used to say they
would fight us with it with swords
that's what they would
do actually nowadays they probably do it
on a plane or something where they're
far away on a drone so they don't have
to engage with the swords themselves
because they are
cowards so I'm going to give you some
points of action because I I feel your
anger I feel your
rage I want you to go home if you have
anybody in your family
a friend that
you have a with you have a dispute a
Discord with resolve it today with the
Muslim people can we get a pledge for
that yes or
no if you know
anybody who is disputing with each other
you're going to step in and try and
resolve it yes or no yes why because if
we do that we're bringing the umah
together and if we bring the umah
together we protect the umah from the s
and the Zionist and these elements that
want to destroy us it's a matter of
survival it is a matter of
survival the second thing I want you to
do is make prolonged and proper Dua in
your to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala that
he gives Palestine and its people
complete victory
complete
Victory it's victory anyway because if
the mar dies he goes to Jenna he goes to
Jenna or she goes to
Jenna otherwise it's victory it's
win-win for us and it's lose lose for
them bear that in mind the conception of
Jenna it is something we can Delight in
and enjoy it's one of the beautiful
gifts we can think oh we're going to be
in a place where there's no bad feeling
those babies that are killed are in a
place inshallah where there's no bad
feeling and there ones insh Allah in the
Hellfire where they would wish to be hit
by missiles burning therein eternally
the cowards that they
are point of action number one fix your
relationships point of action number two
make
Dua and point of action number three use
your your voice wherever you can on
social media on normal media in your
schools anywhere don't let them
intimidate you yes of course we're not
going to say anything illegal but we
need to be able to use this platform you
and I are on the United
Kingdom the so-called first world we
have advantages 95% of the world doesn't
have we have a responsibility therefore
that 95% of the world doesn't have
especially of the Muslim people what
whatever you can
do do it and with that I
[Applause]
conclude